ja weil sie ganz kurz zuvor ist die duh
anfängt ich wollte euch nur sagen morgen
14 uhr kommt endlich mein works online
also mein eigener matches ist hier ein
motiv aber es hat sich auf jeden fall an
viele von euch haben darauf wer so lange
gewartet jetzt ist es endlich soweit ich
mega und weiß ich noch schneller an
wollte am 24.05 nächste woche mittwoch
bin ich in so ist beim guten kollegen
von mir der hat ein konzert im red bull
das ganze beginnt um 19 uhr jeder kann
kommen kommt auf jeden fall vorbei
machen ein paar frösche fotos und so
weiter also ich bin auch da und letzte
aufgespannte video
[Musik]
ich bin nicht in köln ich bin nämlich
gerade zu hause und das ding ist bei mir
im zimmer das ist genau hier ein tag ich
habe hier keinen schreibtisch mehr und
ich brauche aber heute einen
schreibtisch weil heute geht es um diese
teile das habt ihr alles schon mal
gesehen in letzter zeit das sind die
sogenannten switches spinner widgets
pena und um ehrlich zu sein verstehe ich
auch nicht warum diesen krassen hype
haben aber es lockt die auf jeden fall
also dass ich ein gutes gefühl wenn man
die seine hand hat und ich habe überlegt
doch mal hin und zeigt den zuschauern
wie talentiert du bist heute geht es für
mich um die krassesten städtischen fit
spinner tricks der welt und gleichwohl
schlecht bin habe ich mir irgendwann
typen ausgesucht der ist als profi
bezeichnet also er hat so gesagt er ist
ein richtiger mann ich vergess die
anzahl von den dingern features beatrix
web professional bietet auf 58 millionen
klicks dadurch ich war gespannt was der
hre zu bieten aber eher ich meine
schnelligkeit immer wieder geht wie man
das richtig macht
let's go und natürlich alles schon mal
da nach oben
[Musik]
was war das denn
also leute ich war heute ein video über
war gar nicht so schlecht oder also weiß
ich heute im video etwa cool dabei zu
bleiben wirst du funktionieren also
willkommen zu meinem neuen video ich bin
ein richtiger profi
hey leute herzlich willkommen zum neuen
viertels per video ist seit 2000 im navi
dead serious games wieder also hat
gesagt er ist ein profilierter jetzt bin
ich mal gespannt wie schwer die das
jetzt nicht alles ja übrigens frei davon
aber hat ja schon mit denen die leute
jetzt machen haben wir hier ganz locker
wie otto oder wieder das genannt wird
kann nicht sein
zum glück ist das nicht mein
schreibtisch das wasser geklappt hat ich
hab jetzt ich hab jetzt gleich ja mal
und noch mal
afp afp das waren zwei oder dreimal
jahre alter ex klub verlassen musste
dazu was kannst du noch so die neuburger
[Musik]
alte scheiße man ohnehin zu gucken
sie baut möglich die neue lücke aber
ohnehin zu gucken
und hin zu gucken das land die klappen
das glaubt er nicht dass noch ein
vierter versuch nochmal von ihm zugehört
immerhin gefangen ohne hinzugucken
hey ich habs geschafft wo hinten
[Musik]
das war krass sechseinhalb stunden
später das war's jetzt was bleibt ist
das gefühl dass wir schleunigst dieses
von fingern finger das ist so brutal
sterne und spaßig setzt schon seit zehn
minuten und versucht hast aber irgendwie
wird das nichts hatte gesehen habt ihr
gesehen also das was man als mann
[Musik]
wir haben ein alter wir machen aber
weiter
mal gucken wer sich jetzt länger wir
kämpfen jetzt mal zusammen
als er das auch mal eine meisterleistung
scheint sich wieder
wie bin ich plötzlich dazwischen ist
so spart das sind so fucking manchmal
von den beiden stärker als ich gehe mal
kurz
abgefangen
euro der betrag ein billardtisch habe
ich jetzt nicht ihre weiter alter der
war kraft leute wenn ich das schaffe
dann geht ihr aber alle daumen nach oben
[Musik]
2000 jahre später das kann doch nicht
sein dass du auch abgebrochen
viel wichtiger ist dass wir mitmachen
genau wie knapp her sollte es tut mir
leid ich will das wirklich schaffen
nur es geht nicht einfach beide sind
jetzt kaputt ich hab's geschafft also
ich finde den daumen nach oben habe ich
auf jeden fall verdient
ich muss jetzt erst mal was trinken ob
sie schützt teppich recht anstrengend
treibt eine kommentare was er für tricks
gibt oder schickt mir videos wo welche
tricks machen die ich vielleicht einmal
nachmachen kann wir uns ansonsten lagen
wieder um 14 uhr gibt es ein vorbild